couple weeks ago I told you that Donald
Trump jr. and Kellyanne Conway were
ending Secret Service protection and at
the time I said that I found it a little
odd and around that same time there was
a lot of news breaking related to Russia
we learned that there was allegedly an
upcoming indictment against Paul Mann
afford and my instinct at the time was
that the ending of Secret Service
protection for Trump jr. and Kellyanne
Conway although I wasn't sure exactly
how it related to the Trump Russia
scandal my instinct was this might have
to do with them wanting more
unsupervised freedom to go where they
want and meet with whoever they want to
now I got emails from people saying oh
no no no David the only reason that they
are foregoing Secret Service protection
is because the Secret Service is out of
money because Donald Trump has spent so
much money on the Secret Service with
all those trips to his golf resorts and
because he's protecting too many people
with Secret Service but Trump jr.
himself said the reason for ending
Secret Service protections was privacy
concerns which is weird enough already
and I didn't believe the money angle for
a second because Secret Service
protection is one of those things where
if people quote need to be protected in
the eyes of the administration or the
Secret Service they will figure out the
money and shockingly interestingly
Donald Trump jr. is reportedly
reactivating Secret Service protection
according to CNN just a week or two
after ending Secret Service protection
for privacy reasons Trump jr. is
reactivating it did the Secret Service
find new money did Donald Trump jr.
change his mind and I looked into this
in more detail and indeed it might be
connected to Russia listen to this
people have been checking out airplane
tail numbers the tail number is sort of
the unique identifier of a particular
plane and there are some fascinating
coincidences within 24 to 48 hours of
the Trump jr. and Conway ending Secret
Service protection story the plane known
to be used by that Russian billionaire
Oleg Oleg are Oleg Deripaska came to the
United States and landed kind of in a
weird place in Morristown New Jersey
kind of random but it is kind of close
to
Donald Trump's New Jersey golf club the
same day a plane registered to Alisher
Usmanov and reporting the flight plan up
on the screen for you from metalo invest
which is another one of these oleg arts
that landed at JFK also in the New York
area and Viktor Vekselberg splain
another oligarch flew into Newark New
Jersey on September 10th that plane was
still there as of the day in question
September 18th now I am being totally
upfront with you this is purely
speculative but if there was something
going on a great thing to do if you're
trying to have more freedom of movement
and discrete freedom of movement is to
say no more secret service protections
for me but all of a sudden Secret
Service is back on for Donnie jr. and we
already know that Don jr. is not very
good when it comes to crisis management
and I would not want him to be your PR
guy and remember when after news came
out that he met with that Russian lawyer
he kept lying time and time again and
that just made a bigger and bigger hole
for him yeah and ultimately he ended up
releasing the email chain minutes before
it was going to be released anyway by
the New York Times or whoever it was
that had it yeah so Donald Trump jr. not
exactly the best at managing these
situations in a way that's remotely sort
of honest seeming so will we ever learn
more about this I genuinely have no idea
but it is yet another one of these very
unusual coincidences